I'm always trying to be a voice for for
women Christina Aguilera gets candid
backstage at Monday night's taping of
The Voice about raising her children to
embrace feminism and whether or not
she'll be adding to her budding family
love how vocal you've been about female
empowerment and strong women obviously
as a strong woman yourself this be you
needed you know how you're raising
obviously as a mother to a little girl
how are you raising a little girl to
really embrace that feminism well trying
to be an example and and speaking up
about it it's inevitable that it's you
know men men have run the world for a
while and this is a reason why we don't
have a female coach yet because the odds
are always kind of against us next year
though finally two women together I'm
very excited kick their asses girl and
also I think it's important because you
know I I grew up seeing my mom feel so
disempowered by a lot of the abuse that
she endured at my dad's hand so it's
like I'm always trying to be a voice for
for women and trying to be their voice
and a way to use theirs and speak up and
be empowered it's it's important it's
really important we're a strong great
momma and you've got a little boy - so
are you kind of taking the same approach
with him I tell him sometimes after a
hard day's working like babe always been
distracted always be respectful of women
please like Mama's going through it he's
just great actually
he's really great you've got to are you
open to having more you have your hands
full my hands are so full right now